une étoile est née
le nom de leïla fernández est sur toutes
les lèvres depuis quelques jours cette
demi finale aux internationaux des états
unis la québécoise il rêve depuis
toujours son père qui ya émigré de
l'équateur s'est entièrement dédié à la
carrière de sa fille il est devenu son
entraîneur même s'il n'avait aucune
expérience dans le domaine j'ai bien sûr
c'est très bien et sacs faits sont donc
été nombreux pour la famille fernandez
on n'a pas de réel qu'on n'a pas de
maison on a bien enlèvement
c'est ce qu'on a on le dévoué dans le
tennis ils auront finalement eu raison
de croire en les la délai rangs juniors
la lavalloise accumulé les exploits en
2019 elle a été finaliste aux
internationaux d'australie avant d'être
sacrée championne à roland garros en
mars dernier elle a remporté un premier
titre sur le circuit de la wta a montré
à l'âge de 18 ans seulement
après avoir vaincu la troisième joueuse
mondiale naomi osaka et l'ancien numéro
un mondial angélique kerber leylaz
fernandez a éliminé mardi la cinquième
tête de série et dîna svitolina pour se
retrouver dans le carré d'as grâce à son
talent sa ténacité et son charisme
leylaz fernandez est rapidement devenu
la coqueluche de la foule new yorkaise
l'ascension de l'ela fernandez est
fulgurante avant les internationaux des
états unis elle était classé 73e joueur
mondial avec la participation à la
demi-finale elle est maintenant assurée
d'atteindre au moins le 36e rang pour
plat soir de la wta un autre défi de
taille attend maintenant la québécoise
alors qu'elle affrontera jeudi la
deuxième joueuse mondiale arina ce bal
en cas chez les hommes félix urgent et
ali yasin sera aussi des demi finales
une première en carrière pour le
québécois de 21 ans il y aura donc deux
québécois en demi finales dont trois du
grand chelem
un moment historique pour le tennis
canadien et si christine roger
radio-canada croûte montréal
[Applaudissements]